مع احتضان الأمريكيين لخبراء الصحة في الصيف
يركزون على
اتجاهات البيانات الجديدة المزعجة بطريقة ما كدولة
قررنا أن مئات الآلاف من
الأمريكيين يموتون من هذا الفيروس على ما
يرام وهذا أمر لا يصدق بالنسبة لي
تتنبأ النمذجة الجديدة بما يقرب من 170.000
حالة وفاة مرتبطة بـ Cova 19 في الولايات المتحدة.  بحلول الأول من أكتوبر ، أصبح
ما يقرب من 80 في المائة من أسرة العناية المركزة في ولاية أريزونا
قيد الاستخدام الآن ، وأعتقد أن
النقص الحاد في أسرة العناية المركزة هو
سيناريو الكابوس الذي
كان سببًا كاملاً في
تأكيدنا على تسطيح المنحنى في بعض
الولايات الأولى لإعادة فتح المنحنى
لا يسوي فلوريدا ما زالت تنشر
أكثر من ألف حالة جديدة يوميًا في
ساوث كارولينا ، فقد ارتفعت التعدادات اليومية
على مدار الأسبوعين الماضيين ، فأنا أكثر
قلقًا بشأن كوفين 19 في ساوث
كارولينا أكثر مما كنت عليه من قبل في
الكثير من الغرب والجنوب أيضًا
الإبلاغ عن ارتفاع في ناشفيل
يؤخر الآن مرحلته التالية من إعادة الافتتاح
استجابة لارتفاع عدد الحالات الجديدة
تم تأجيل معرض ولاية أيوا الأيقوني
للمرة الأولى منذ الحرب العالمية الثانية ، ولا توجد
أبقار بالزبدة ولا توجد حملة
بحثية جديدة من المملكة المتحدة لتعزيز قضية
يمكن أن يساعد ارتداء قناع يشير إلى استخدامه على نطاق واسع في تجنب
الموجة الثانية ، فهو يتوافق مع
العديد من الدراسات الأخرى التي
تظهر بشكل أساسي أنه إذا حصلت على الأغلبية  من
الأشخاص الذين يرتدون أقنعة
، ليس للفيروس مكانًا يذهبون إليه حقًا ، وفي شيكاغو ، أجريت
عملية زرع رئة مزدوجة ناجحة
لامرأة في العشرينات من عمرها أمضت ستة أسابيع على
جهاز التنفس الصناعي تكافح الفيروس
أمس ، ابتسمت وأخبرتني
بجملة واحدة فقط قالت دكتور شكرا لك
لعدم التخلي عن القليل من الأمل في
الأوقات غير المستقرة.
خطر الوفاة من كوفات 19 قام
باحثون بدراسة سجلات أكثر من
2800 مريض عولجوا في ووهان الصين ، يقول
أحد المؤلفين الرئيسيين للدراسة إن
ما يقرب من نصف المرضى الذين ماتوا يعانون من
ارتفاع ضغط الدم وهي
نسبة أعلى بكثير مقارنة بأولئك
الذين يعانون من كوفا خفيفة.  19 عرضًا ،
نظرت المجموعة أيضًا في أدوية ارتفاع ضغط الدم التي
كان يخشى بعض الأطباء من أن مثبطات الآس 2 لها
وأن حاصرات مستقبلات الأنجيوتنسين يمكن أن تجعل الأمر أسهل
بالنسبة لمرضى ارتفاع ضغط الدم.  الفيروس يصيب الخلايا ولكن
الدراسة وجدت العكس بناءً على
النتائج التي توصلوا إليها ، اقترح الباحثون أن المرضى
لم يتوقفوا أو يغيروا علاجهم المعتاد
المضاد لارتفاع ضغط الدم وأقل
تعليمات من طبيب يقولون إنه من
المهم لمن يعانون من ارتفاع
ضغط الدم أن يدركوا مخاطرهم المتزايدة
لتناول الطعام الجيد  يعتنون بأنفسهم خلال
هذا الوباء ، وإذا كانوا مصابين
بفيروس كورونا ، فقد يحتاجون إلى مزيد من
العناية الطبية للدقيقة الصحية اليوم ،
ويتطلع ماندي
في مختبر على بعد 6500 ميل تقريبًا من
الباحثين في ووهان في بيركلي كاليفورنيا
إلى الوراء للعثور على أدلة حول كيفية
المساعدة  يحارب البشر فيروسات كورونا مثل
copa90
ولكن أعتقد بطريقة ما أن هناك الكثير في الواقع
يمكننا تعلمه من الخفافيش التي تعرف أن هذه
المجموعة من الحيوانات كانت موجودة منذ
ملايين السنين ، كيف يمكننا أن ننظر إلى
تاريخهم مع الفيروسات ونأخذ هذه
المعرفة ونفكر في العلاجات
والعلاجات لأنفسنا
يعتقد العلماء أن فهم
نظام مناعة الخفافيش يمكن أن يساعد في تطوير
خطة معركة الإنسان لمحاربة هذه
الأمراض على نطاق عالمي ،
إنها فرصة.
يمكن للفيروسات التي يكون
حملها أعلى بكثير من البشر ، فلنتعرف على السبب
والاستخدام الذي
يعتقد العلماء أن Coppa 19 له
جذوره في مجتمع من خفافيش حدوة الحصان
في جنوب شرق الصين ،
وتمثل هذه الخفافيش الخاصة مجموعة فرعية صغيرة جدًا
من الخفافيش حدوة الحصان ، وكلها سميت
بهذا الشكل.  من أنوفهم في الواقع ، هناك
تنوع مذهل بين تلك الأنواع من
الخفافيش يمكن العثور عليها تعيش في جميع أنحاء
العالم في كل قارة باستثناء القارة
القطبية الجنوبية ،
ولكن تنوع
الخفافيش وقدراتها الفريدة هو أيضًا ما يجعل من
الصعب مواجهتها عندما يتعلق
الأمر بمرضها  الثدييات الوحيدة
القادرة على الطيران فعليًا حتى تتمكن من
نشر الفيروسات بسهولة إلى حيوانات أخرى
في مجتمعات بعض أنواع الخفافيش
تهاجر آلاف الأميال ومن ثم
الفيروسات التي تنقلها على طول
طرق الهجرة هذه ، وعلى الرغم
من أن بعض الخفافيش الممرضة تلعب دور المضيف
لتسبب لهم المرض مثل داء الكلب ، فإن لديهم أيضًا
قدرة فريدة على استضافة
بعض الفيروسات ومقاومة بعض الفيروسات دون أن
يمرضوا فهم كيفية القيام بذلك.  تتعايش الخفافيش
مع الأمراض من الأهمية بمكان أن تتمتع الخفافيش
بعلاقة فريدة جدًا مع
مسببات الأمراض عمومًا ، فهي تتمتع
ببيولوجيا فريدة وتسمح لها
بالتعايش مع مسببات الأمراض بطرق مختلفة